SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ADAM. ALVARADO. GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DARLEY DODD. DURAZZO.
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES LAIRD. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WHAT? OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL.
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING. THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN. AFTER
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
TODAY, LET US REFLECT ON
DIFFERENT WAYS TO PRAY FROM
NAOMI SHIHAB NYE, AN ARAB
AMERICAN POET. THERE WAS THE
METHOD OF KNEELING, A FINE
METHOD. IF YOU LIVED IN A
COUNTRY WHERE STONES WERE
SMOOTH, THE WOMEN DREAMED
WISTFULLY OF BLEACHED COURTYARDS
, HIDDEN CORNERS WHERE KNEE FIT
ROCK. THERE WERE THE MEN WHO HAD
BEEN SHEPHERDS SO LONG THEY
WALKED LIKE SHEEP UNDER THE
OLIVE TREES. THEY RAISED THEIR
ARMS HERE US WE HAVE PAIN ON
EARTH. WE HAVE SO MUCH PAIN.
THERE IS NO PLACE TO STORE IT.
AT NIGHT THE MEN AGED HEARTILY
AND WERE HAPPY IN SPITE OF THE
PAIN, BECAUSE THERE WAS ALSO
HAPPINESS. SOME PRIZED THE
PILGRIMAGE, WRAPPING THEMSELVES
IN NEW WHITE LINEN. WHEN THEY
ARRIVED AT MECCA, THEY WOULD
CIRCLE THE HOLY PLACES AND
RETURN THERE LEAN FACES, HOUSING
MYSTERY, WHILE FOR CERTAIN
COUSINS AND GRANDMOTHERS, AS THE
PILGRIMAGE OCCURRED DAILY,
LUGGING WATER FROM THE SPRING OR
BALANCING THE BASKETS OF GRAPES,
AND THERE WERE THE ONES WHO
DIDN'T CARE ABOUT PRAYING. THE
YOUNG ONES, THE ONES WHO HAD
BEEN TO AMERICA. THEY TOLD THE
OLD ONES YOU WERE WASTING YOUR
TIME. THE OLD ONES PRAYED FOR
THE YOUNG ONES. THEY PRAYED FOR
ALLAH TO MEND THEIR BRAINS, AND
OCCASIONALLY THERE WOULD BE ONE
WHO DID NONE OF THIS. THE OLD
MAN, FAWZI, THE FOOL WHO BEAT
EVERYONE AT DOMINOES, INSISTED
HE SPOKE WITH GOD AS HE SPOKE
WITH GOATS AND WAS FAMOUS FOR
HIS LAUGH. SO GRACIOUS GOD OF
MANY NAMES, WE THANK YOU FOR THE
DIVERSITY OF WAYS TO PRAY AND
HOWEVER WE PRAY. GRANT THIS. WE
MAY PRAY IN AMAZEMENT AND
GRATITUDE THAT WE ARE HERE NOW,
CHOOSING TO BRING HOPE AND
ENCOURAGEMENT TO THOSE WE SERVE.
AMEN MEMBERS AND GUESTS, PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY,
JUSTICE
.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
BRIEF PAUSE, SO I'M GOING TO ASK
FOLKS TO COME TO THEIR DESKS FOR
A MINUTE.
I'M GOING TO ASK MEMBERS TO MOVE
TO THEIR DESKS, PLEASE. AND TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. MEMBERS WE'RE NOW MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
FIRST UP IS SENATOR GROVE FROM
THE MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, TODAY I WANT TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU PARIS HILTON,
ALONG WITH HER STAFF FROM HER
NONPROFIT, 1111 MEDIA IMPACT AND
SURVIVORS OF THE TROUBLED TEEN
INDUSTRY. PARIS HILTON IS A CEO
OF 1111 MEDIA IMPACT AND HAS
MADE IT HER MISSION TO EMPOWER,
EMPOWER SURVIVORS IN THE
TROUBLED TEEN INDUSTRY AS SHE
HAS USED HER GLOBAL PLATFORM TO
BRING AWARENESS TO CREATE
INITIATIVES TO SUPPORT VICTIMS.
PARIS'S DOCUMENTARY THIS IS
PARIS IS A MUST WATCH. IT'S BEEN
VIEWED OVER 79 MILLION TIMES AND
IT GOES THROUGH THE PHYSICAL,
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND ABUSE
EXPERIENCED BY A TEENAGER IN
THESE NUMEROUS RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES IN THE
TROUBLED TEEN INDUSTRY. HER
ADVOCACY HAS RESULTED IN PUBLIC
AWARENESS IN THE TROUBLED TEEN
INDUSTRY. SHE'S GIVEN A VOICE.
SHE'S USED HER CELEBRITY STATUS
TO HIGHLIGHT THIS INDUSTRY. IT
STARTED ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO,
SHE TOLD HER STORY, WHICH WAS
VERY TRAUMATIC AND HARD TO TELL
THE FIRST TIME. AND THEN JUST
LAST WEEK, SHE WENT TO JAMAICA
TO RESCUE AND HIGHLIGHT SOME
THINGS THAT WERE GOING ON IN A
FACILITY IN JAMAICA WHERE ONE
CALIFORNIA BOY, THERE WERE OTHER
BOYS, BUT ONE CALIFORNIA BOY WAS
BEING ABUSED. AFTER SHE
HIGHLIGHTED THAT STORY JUST LAST
WEEK, A LOT INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE RUNNING THAT FACILITY WERE
ARRESTED AND PROSECUTED FOR
CHILD ABUSE. SHE IS SHE IS
SPOTLIGHTING AND USING HER GLAM
POWER. I GUESS YOU WOULD CALL
IT, TO HIGHLIGHT THIS INDUSTRY
AND TO BRING AWARENESS TO THE
TROUBLED TEEN INDUSTRY AND THE
HORRIFIC THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN
THESE INSTITUTIONS. AND SHE'S A
CHAMPION FOR CHILDREN. PLEASE
HELP ME WELCOME PARIS HILTON.
FOR PARIS TO HAVE A VOICE, BUT
ZOE SCHREIBER WOULD NOT HAVE A
VOICE IF IT WASN'T FOR PARIS.
HIGHLIGHTING HER. ZOE TOLD HER
STORY PUBLICLY AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE JUST A FEW MINUTES
AGO, WHERE SHE TOLD THE STORY OF
BEING ABUSED IN ONE OF THESE
FACILITIES AND HOW HARD IT WAS
TO BE SEPARATED FROM HER FAMILY.
SO PLEASE WELCOME ZOE TO THE
FLOOR. FOR. ALSO, WE HAVE
CHELSEA HERE WHO IS A MEMBER, AN
ATTORNEY, A LAW ATTORNEY WHO HAS
REPRESENTED OVER 25,000 YOUTH IN
THE SACRAMENTO. THE PLACER
COUNTY AREA AND LOS ANGELES
DEFENDING THEM AGAINST,
ATROCITIES THAT TAKE PLACE
AGAINST THEM. SO PLEASE WELCOME,
SORRY. CHELSEA. CHELSEA IS A
SURVIVOR. I'M SORRY. I REALLY
BOTCHED THAT ONE. CHELSEA IS
ALSO A SURVIVOR. LUCIANA OH,
SOMEDAY. SOMEDAY. WE'RE SPEAKING
PROPHETICALLY INTO HER LIFE THAT
SHE'S GOING TO BE AN ADVOCATE
AND A LAWYER FOR THESE TEENS.
BUT THESE ARE SURVIVORS, DÍAS
COLLEAGUES THAT REALLY HAVE A
STORY TO TELL. IF YOU HAVEN'T
WATCHED THIS IS PARIS, IT'S A
YOUTUBE DOCUMENTARY. YOU SHOULD.
AND IT IS REALLY JUST I TELLING
WHAT HAPPENS IN OUR STATE AND
ACROSS THIS NATION. SO PLEASE
WELCOME OUR GUEST. I DON'T MIND,
YOU CAN INTRODUCE US AND, IF YOU
GUYS WANT TO TAKE A PHOTO, IS
THAT MY JOB ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
WELCOME YOU. AND NOW, MEMBERS,
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
PHOTO, NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
MEMBERS. IF WE CAN FIND OUR WAY
BACK TO OUR DESKS, WE CAN
CONTINUE ON WITH TODAY'S AGENDA.
IF YOU CAN MAKE YOUR WAY BACK TO
YOUR DESK.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO GET BACK TO YOUR
DESK. SO WE CAN CONTINUE WITH
TODAY'S AGENDA. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WHILE STILL ON
PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR, WE'RE
NOW RECOGNIZING SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS, WE'RE TRYING
TO GET YOUR ATTENTION. PLEASE
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
COLLEAGUES, IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
RECOGNIZE BOTH BELLARMINE
COLLEGE PREPARATORY AND
PRESENTATION HIGH SCHOOL ON THE
SENATE FLOOR. THESE STUDENTS ARE
JOINED BY TEACHERS AND PARENTS
TODAY, INCLUDING FORMER ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER PRO TEM NORA CAMPOS FROM
SAN JOSE BELLARMINE. MY ALMA
MATER IS AS A COMMUNITY OF
EDUCATION AND FAITH. FOUNDED IN
1851, IT'S THE OLDEST JESUIT
SECONDARY SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA.
BELLARMINE'S MISSION IS TO
CULTIVATE STUDENTS GIFTS AND
TALENTS AND ULTIMATELY PUT THOSE
TALENTS TO THE SERVICE OF
OTHERS. PRESENTATION HIGH SCHOOL
IS A COLLEGE PREPARATORY SCHOOL
FOR GIRLS IN SAN JOSE. IT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN 1962.
PRESENTATION VALUES A BALANCED
APPROACH TO EDUCATION,
ENCOURAGING STUDENTS TO DEVELOP
SPIRITUALLY, ACADEMICALLY, AND
PERSONALLY. THE SCHOOL'S VISION
IS TO EMPOWER YOUTH WOMEN TO
BECOME FEARLESS AND FAITHFUL
LEADERS. MY OFFICE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH THESE
STUDENTS DURING FALL RECESS,
WHERE THEY ADVOCATED FOR THE
ISSUES THAT MATTER MOST TO YOUNG
PEOPLE, INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH.
I'M PROUD TO WITNESS THEIR
ADVOCACIES, DIRECT INFLUENCE ON
THIS BODY. IT'S BEEN A JOY TO
WORK WITH STUDENTS FROM BOTH
THESE SCHOOLS IN COLLABORATION
ON TRYING TO BRING WELLNESS
CENTERS TO SCHOOL CAMPUSES UP
AND DOWN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I KNOW, PROBABLY TO
A PERSON IN THE SENATE, WE
APPRECIATE THAT EFFORT AND THEIR
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE
IN THIS STATE. THESE STUDENTS
ARE PASSIONATE, CRITICAL
THINKERS, AND I'M INSPIRED BY
THEIR INITIATIVE. LET US ALL
RISE AND RECOGNIZE THESE FUTURE
LEADERS WITH US ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR ALL, ALL OF
YOU FOR VISITING SACRAMENTO
TODAY AND ENGAGING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. AND THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. AND
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE
.
OKAY. MEMBERS CONTINUING UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. I WANT
TO RECOGNIZE
.
ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS
UNDER. UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. WE WANT TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR BRADFORD FROM THE
MAJORITY LEADER'S DESK. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND IT'S TRULY AN
HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY. AND IT'S
TRULY MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME
SOME AMAZING WOMEN OF DELTA
SIGMA THETA SORORITY FOR THEIR
38TH ANNUAL DELTA DAYS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND HERE AT THE
CAPITOL. THEY'RE THE WOMEN WHO
ARE NEATLY ATTIRED IN THE
CRIMSON AND CREAM OF DELTA SIGMA
THETA SORORITY, INCORPORATED,
WAS FOUNDED ON JANUARY 13TH,
1913, ON THE CAMPUS OF HOWARD
UNIVERSITY BY 22 AMAZING
COLLEGIATE WOMEN. AND THIS YEAR
THEY CELEBRATE THEIR 100TH AND
11TH YEAR OF SERVICE. DELTA
SIGMA THETA IS A PRIVATE,
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WHOSE
PURPOSE IS TO PROVIDE AID AND
SUPPORT THROUGH VARIOUS PROGRAMS
AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD. WITH A PRIMARY FOCUS
ON THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. SOCIAL ACTION IS AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE SORORITY'S
POLITICAL AWARENESS AND
INVOLVEMENT PROGRAM. DELTAS MEET
ANNUALLY WITH THEIR RESPECTIVE
FEDERAL, STATE, AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO ADVOCATE FOR ISSUES
AFFECTING THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WHAT US TODAY ON THE FLOOR ARE
THE FAR WEST REGIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE, JOY MOORE,
CHRISTIAN MCGUIRE, TERRI LYNN
LOVE, KANISHA GREEN, KATRINA
DUNN AND LEONA BRIDGES. AND
PLEASE WELCOME THE REST OF THEIR
GUESTS HERE IN THE GALLERY. ALSO
HERE TO CELEBRATE AGAIN THEIR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCACY DAY AND NOT
ONLY ARE THEIR AMAZING SORORITY
IN AND OF THEMSELVES, THEY'RE
ONE OF NINE OF THE DIVINE NINE
OF THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
SORORITIES AND FRATERNITIES HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES. SO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE, I SAY WELCOME, WELCOME.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE.
MEMBERS ARE WELCOME TO JOIN IN.
ANOTHER PHOTOGRAPH ON THE FLOOR
.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO GET BACK TO OUR AGENDA. SO IF
MEMBERS CAN MAKE THEIR WAY BACK
TO THEIR DESKS, WE WOULD
APPRECIATE IT. MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM FOUR. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ,
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS,
WE NEED YOU TO TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATION OFF THE FLOOR AND
RETURN TO YOUR DESKS IF POSSIBLE
. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR APRIL 8TH, 2024 THROUGH
APRIL 11TH, 2024 WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
SENATE CLERK. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE SENATE SECOND
READING SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1016 WITH AMENDMENTS
1120, WITH AMENDMENTS 1397, WITH
AMENDMENTS 1355, WITH AMENDMENTS
1319, WITH AMENDMENTS 910, WITH
AMENDMENTS 963. WITH AMENDMENTS
1257, WITH AMENDMENTS READING.
DEAN READ. NOW MOVING TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE
THREE. SENATOR LAIRD. HE'S
PREPARED. SENATOR LAIRD, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. FIRST ONE IS FILE
ITEM 12. THE CONFIRMATION OF
ROSSI BRA AND MARK GHILARDUCCI
FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. IS. MISS BRA
IS A BUSINESS OWNER IN KERN
COUNTY, AS WELL AS FOUNDER OF
THE BAKERSFIELD SIKH WOMEN'S
ASSOCIATION. THE HIGHLIGHT OF
HER HEARING WAS WHEN SHE LET US
KNOW THE SICK WORD SHE USES WHEN
VISITED BY THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE IN HER OWN
DISTRICT, THAT IS PETORCA, WHICH
TRANSLATES TO FIRECRACKER. MR.
GHILARDUCCI PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
BOTH WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON A50 VOTE ON MARCH
20TH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE, SENATOR
DODD? YES, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF MARK GHILARDUCCI.
AS MOST OF YOU KNOW, HE WAS OUR
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
DIRECTOR HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HE'S THE TYPE OF
INDIVIDUAL THAT'S ONE TEAM, ONE
FIGHT. I THINK HE'LL DO A GREAT
JOB FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
FOR THE CSU TRUSTEES.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SENATOR LEHRER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON APPOINTMENT
FILE ITEM 12. ALLEN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. JONES LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO OCHOA
BORG. AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALVARADO. GILL AYE. JONES AYE.
NILO HE'S NOT HERE. HE'S NOT
HERE. EYES 39 NOES! ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM 13. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. THERE WE ARE.
FILE ITEM 13 IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF THE FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS TO
THE LAW REVISION COMMISSION.
MARIA BE VICTOR KING AND RICK
SIMPSON. MISS BE IS NEW TO THE
COMMISSION. MR. KING AND MR.
SIMPSON ARE REAPPOINTMENTS. THEY
FIRST JOINED THE COMMISSION IN
2012 AND 2019 RESPECTIVELY. THEY
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL 3RD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
, ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLE. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLASER.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MEN. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. WHEN AYE. NILO. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE CIERTO AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER. AYE.
GROVE NILO. AYES 38. NOES ZERO.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
NOW WE'RE MOVING TO OUR FINAL
APPOINTMENT. FILE ITEM 14.
SENATOR LEHRER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. FINAL ITEM 14 IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR DAVID
CARILLO FOR REAPPOINTMENT TO THE
LAW. REVISION COMMISSION. HE'S
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
LECTURER IN RESIDENCE AT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION CENTER
AT UC BERKELEY. HE SERVED ON THE
COMMISSION SINCE 2019. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON APRIL 3RD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENT? HEARING. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NØ DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. NO. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN NO. NILO OCHOA.
BOGUE PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. NILO.
OCHOA. BOGUE. NO NO. AYES 32.
NOES SEVEN. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO SENATE. THIRD
READING. WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS.
FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM 27.
SENATOR CIERTO. IS HE READY? HE
IS SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 128
BY SENATOR CIERTO RELATIVE TO
CRIME VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK.
SENATOR SECRETO, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
AND COLLEAGUES, I AM PROUD TO
BRING BEFORE YOU TODAY SCR 128,
WHICH ESTABLISHES THE WEEK OF
APRIL 21ST THROUGH APRIL 27TH AS
CRIME VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS YEAR, THE THEME
IS HOW WOULD YOU HELP? OPTIONS,
SERVICES AND HOPE FOR CRIME
SURVIVORS? IT ASKS ALL OF US HOW
WE CAN HELP CRIME VICTIMS. ARE
YOU PREPARED IF SOMEONE CONFIDES
IN YOU ABOUT A VICTIMIZATION?
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE
SERVICES AVAILABLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY? IT'S ABOUT RESTORING
POWER TO SURVIVORS WHO OFTEN
FEEL POWERLESS IN THE AFTERMATH
OF A SERIOUS CRIME, CREATING
SAFE ENVIRONMENTS FOR CRIME
VICTIMS AND ARMING THEM WITH
INFORMATION ON HOW TO NAVIGATE
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE VITAL IN THIS
EFFORT. CALIF HAS BEEN AN
INNOVATOR IN THE VICTIMS RIGHTS
MOVEMENT FOR GENERATIONS,
ESTABLISHING THE FIRST VICTIM
COMPENSATION PROGRAM IN THE
NATION IN 1965. OTHER
TRAILBLAZING EFFORTS INCLUDE THE
WOMEN'S ADVOCATES AND HAVEN
HOUSE IN PASADENA, WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE FIRST SHELTERS
FOR BATTERED WOMEN IN THE NATION
IN 1976, AND MOTHERS AGAINST
DRUNK DRIVING, FOUNDED IN 1980.
WITH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
CHAPTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
MOREOVER CALIFORNIA HAS
ENSHRINED VICTIMS RIGHTS IN THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. WITH THE
PASSAGE OF PROPOSITION 8 IN
1982, THE VICTIMS BILL OF
RIGHTS, AND REAFFIRMED IN 2008
WITH THE PASSAGE OF PROP NINE
KNOWN AS MARSY'S LAW, IT IS OUR
DUTY TO CONTINUE THE EFFORT TO
BETTER COORDINATE AND IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF SERVICES PROVIDED
TO VICTIMS AND WITNESSES
OBSERVING CRIME VICTIMS WEEK
PROMOTES AWARENESS OF VICTIMS
ISSUES WHILE ACKNOWLEDGING THE
COMBINED EFFORTS OF CITIZENS,
THE GOVERNMENT AND THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO IMPROVE VICTIM
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN SENDING A MESSAGE TO
VICTIMS OF CRIME THAT THEY ARE
NOT ALONE AND THEY HAVE SUPPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SEEING NONE. MEMBERS.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
ITEM? SEEING NONE AYES 39. NOES
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM 33. SENATOR JONES, HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ. SENATE BILL 1048 BY
SENATOR JONES AND AQUILINA. LAND
USE. SENATOR JONES, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, MY PRESENTATION IS ONLY
SLIGHTLY LONGER THAN THE
PRECEDING ONE, BUT I RISE TO IS
OKAY TO LAUGH. THAT WAS A JOKE.
YEAH. OKAY. I'M PRESENTING FILE
ITEM 33, SB 1048, WHICH CLEANS
UP THE SENATE BILL 1214 FROM
LAST YEAR RELATING TO
ARCHITECTURAL DRAWINGS SUBMITTED
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS. IT PASSED LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON CONSENT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM? HEARING SEEING NONE
MEMBERS. THIS TOO IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO THIS
ITEM? SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
AYES 39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM 41.
SENATOR GONZALES, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE RESOLUTION 84 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO
KHMER NEW YEAR. SENATOR
GONZALES. THANK YOU. MR.
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SR 84, WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE WEEK OF APRIL
13TH THROUGH THE 16TH AS A NEW
YEAR IN 2024, MY NEW YEAR OR
CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR, IS ALSO
KNOWN AS MAHA SANGRITA AND
COINCIDES WITH THE TRADITIONAL
SOLAR NEW YEAR, ALSO CELEBRATED
ACROSS SOUTHEAST ASIA AND PARTS
OF INDIA, BANGLADESH, NEPAL,
MYANMAR, LAOS AND THAILAND. IN
CAMBODIA, THE NEW YEAR IS
CELEBRATED BY A THREE DAY PUBLIC
HOLIDAY WITH VARIOUS ACTS OF
WORSHIP PERFORMED EACH DAY, AND
TODAY, CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF CAMBODIAN
AMERICANS. AND AS I OFTEN SAY,
ESPECIALLY IN THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH, IT, IN LONG BEACH, WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A STRETCH CALLED
CAMBODIA TOWN, WHICH IS FROM
ANAHEIM STREET IN DOWNTOWN LONG
BEACH TO DOWNTOWN LONG BEACH,
WHICH IS A VAST PART OF OUR
CITY. AND FOR THE CAMBODIAN
DIASPORA IN CALIFORNIA, THE NEW
YEAR REPRESENTS A TIME TO HONOR
CULTURAL HERITAGE WITH FOOD,
WITH DANCE. AND IN LONG BEACH, A
HUGE PARADE LASTING MANY HOURS.
BUT IT'S GREAT. SO COLLEAGUES, I
HOPE YOU WILL JOIN ME IN
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZING MY NEW
YEAR. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING AND SEEING. NONE.
MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE ITEM
41? HEARING. SEEING NONE. AYES
39. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES NOW. MEMBERS. WE'RE
MOVING TO SENATOR BECKER. HE'S
YOUR SECRETARY. YOU MAY READ
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION 14 BY
SENATOR BECKER. RELATIVE TO
TAXATION. SEN. BECKER. AYE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AS
TODAY IS TAX DAY, IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT I RISE TO
PRESENT SJR 14 ON DEFERRED
COMPENSATION. AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY FROM THE START THAT THIS
RESOLUTION ISN'T ABOUT ONE
PLAYER OR ONE TEAM, BUT REALLY
ABOUT ENSURING FAIRNESS IN OUR
TAX SYSTEM. HAVING SAID THAT, IN
DECEMBER, LOS ANGELES DODGERS
BASEBALL TEAM SIGNED A TEN YEAR,
$700 MILLION CONTRACT WITH
PITCHER AND HITTER SHOHEI
OHTANI. THAT CURRENT CONTRACT IS
STRUCTURED SO THAT OHTANI WILL
DEFER $68 MILLION ANNUALLY. TÊ
ONLY RECEIVING $2 MILLION PER
YEAR FOR TEN YEARS AND THUS
POTENTIALLY AVOIDING $90 MILLION
IN STATE TAXES IF HE WERE TO
RESIDE OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN THAT DEFERRED COMPENSATION
IS PAID. FRIENDS THIS IS A
MASSIVE HIDDEN BALL TRICK. BUT
REALLY, THIS ISN'T JUST AGAIN.
AGAIN, THIS IS JUST NOT ABOUT
ONE PLAYER. IT'S REALLY ABOUT A
PRECEDENT THAT ALLOWS HIGH
INCOME EARNERS TO SKIRT PAYING
THEIR FAIR SHARE. DEFERRED
COMPENSATION WAS MEANT FOR SMALL
AMOUNTS OF INCOME FOR PENSION
INCOME. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DISCUSSION AT THE US SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, IT WAS
ORIGINALLY GOING TO BE CAPPED AT
$30,000. AND THEN SOMEHOW AT THE
LAST MINUTE, THE CAP GOT REMOVED
AND THE US SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE REPORTS ACTUALLY
WARNED ABOUT SUCH A SITUATION.
AND THE ABSENCE OF A CAP.
DEFERRING COMPENSATION CREATES
AN UNBALANCED TAX STRUCTURE, AND
ULTIMATELY IT FURTHERS INCOME
INEQUALITY. K¾T LIMITS ON
DEFERRED COMPENSATION FOR HIGH
INCOME EARNERS CAN, BY CONTRAST,
ESTABLISH A FAIR TAX SYSTEM AND
MAINTAIN POTENTIAL STATE
REVENUE. I'M GRATEFUL TO OUR
COMPTROLLER, MALIA COHEN, FOR
HER PARTNERSHIP ON THIS. THIS
RESOLUTION WILL URGE CONGRESS,
WHICH ULTIMATELY HAS TO ACT
HERE. IT WILL URGE CONGRESS TO
ESTABLISH A REASONABLE CAP ON
DEFERRED COMPENSATION TO RECTIFY
THIS IMBALANCE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING SEEING? NONE.
OH, THERE YOU ARE, SENATOR SATO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. SO THE REASON THAT A
BALLPLAYER SUCH AS MR. OHTANI
WOULD DEFER ALL THIS IS BECAUSE
IT COSTS SO DANG MUCH, AND OUR
TAXES ARE SO HIGH THAT THEY HAVE
TO COME UP WITH CREATIVE MEANS
OF DOING THEIR SALARY. AND ALSO
REMEMBER HE IS PAYING TAX REYES
ON ALL OF THE MONEY THAT HE
MAKES FROM ALL OF HIS
ENDORSEMENTS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT. SO HE'S COMPLAINING HE'S
ALREADY PAYING A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT. BUT WHAT WE REALLY
SHOULD CONSIDER IS WHY PEOPLE
WOULD COME, WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH ALL THESE CREATIVE MEANS
TO PROTECT SOME OF THE MONEY
THAT THEY MAKE. THE OTHER THING
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER IS IF
YOU WANT GOOD BALL TEAMS, THEN
YOU BETTER BE CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT
WE DO HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
DISSUADE GREAT ATHLETES FROM
SIGNING WITH TEAMS THAT ARE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE IF I WERE
A BALLPLAYER AND I HAD A CHOICE
OF MAKING $700 MILLION HERE OR
MAKING $700 MILLION IN A STATE
THAT DOES NOT EVEN TAX, STATE
TAXES, I WOULD PROBABLY GO PLAY
FOR THAT TEAM. AND, AND LEAVE US
HIGH AND DRY AND THAT WOULD
LEAVE OUR GOOD SENATORS FROM THE
SAN FRANCISCO AREA VERY SAD,
BECAUSE THEIR TEAMS WOULD NOT NO
LONGER BE COMPETITIVE. SO AS
MUCH AS I DON'T LIKE THE FACT
THAT, THE THAT A PERSON CAN MAKE
THAT MUCH MONEY PERIOD IN SPORTS
, IT'S OUR SYSTEM THAT IS
DRIVING PEOPLE TO DO THESE
CREATIVE THINGS. AND I TO
CELEBRATE TODAY AS TAX DAY AS MY
WIFE IS A TAX PERSON AND THIS IS
HER TAX FREEDOM DAY. BUT
REMEMBER TAX FREEDOM DAY FOR THE
REST OF US ISN'T UNTIL JULY. SO
ANYWAY, WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE,
AND, AND FOR US TO GO
CONTEMPLATE WHAT KIND OF TEAMS
WE WANT IN THE FUTURE AND WHY
THIS IS HAPPENING IN THE FIRST
PLACE. IT'S BECAUSE WE TAX OUR
CITIZENS WAY TOO MUCH. THE
PEOPLE THAT MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
WILL FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
AROUND IT NO MATTER WHAT, EVEN
IF THEY HAVE TO PLAY FOR A TEAM
OVER IN, SAY, WASHINGTON. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, THIS BILL CERTAINLY IS
A HOME RUN FROM MY POINT OF
VIEW. AND LET ME EXPLAIN.
EXPLAIN WHY NOT JUST FOR
CALIFORNIA, BUT FOR THE OTHER 49
STATES WHEN YOU WHEN YOU PLAY IN
MISSOURI, YOU PLAY THE
CARDINALS. THAT THAT OBLIGATION
THAT IS ON YOU, THAT PLAYER OWES
AN OBLIGATION. THEY'RE WORKING
IN MISSOURI. AND SO WHEN THEIR
ACCOUNTANT DOES THEIR TAX FORMS,
THEY'RE FILLING IT OUT FOR ALL
THE STATES IN WHICH THE MEMBERS
HAVE PLAYED IN. SO THE
RESOLUTION TO CONGRESS IS A
WORTHY ONE. AND IT IS SOMETHING
THAT'S BENEFICIAL TO ALL THE
STATES THAT HAVE A TEAM, SOME OF
THEM ARE GOING TO, YOU KNOW,
LIKE TO HAVE THE DODGERS MOVE
THERE, BUT, ANYWAY, IT'S A GOOD
BILL, AND I THINK IT'S A GOOD
TAX POLICY AND I SUPPORT IT AND
URGE YOUR YES VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING.
SEEING. NONE. SENATOR BECKER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? WELL,
THANK YOU FOR THE DEBATE, YOU
KNOW, A COUPLE OF POINTS. NUMBER
ONE, MAKES US GRATEFUL FOR ALL
THOSE WHO ARE PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE, ALL THE ATHLETES AND
OTHERS WHO ARE HIGH EARNERS. WE
DO HAVE HIGH MARGINAL TAX RATE.
THEY CHOOSE TO BE HERE AND WORK
HERE IN OUR GREAT STATE. AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR, OUR
WONDERFUL RESOURCES, NATURAL
RESOURCES AND, OUR, OUR VALUES
PARTICIPATE IN OUR VALUES AND
POLICIES. SO IT MAKES ME
GRATEFUL TO ALL THOSE WHO DO
CHOOSE TO DO THIS. AND SO THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT FAIRNESS AND
MAKING SURE THAT EIGHT BALL
PLAYERS, BUT ALSO CORPORATE
EXECUTIVES, THERE'S MANY
CORPORATE EXECUTIVES. THIS IS
REALLY A BAD PRECEDENT, REALLY A
VERY BAD PRECEDENT FOR OUR
STATE. SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
NIP THIS IN THE BUD AND MAKE
SURE THAT THIS WE CAN HAVE LAWS
THAT APPLY EQUALLY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND WITH THAT I WILL SAY
GO GIANTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON FILE ITEM 44. ALAN AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. GALLEY. NO. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE NGUYEN. NO. NILO OCHOA. BOGH
NO. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO AYE.
CIERTO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER. GROVE.
NILO. AYES 32. NOES SIX. THE
MEASURE PASSES NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AS ANY MEMBER WISHING
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HEARING. SEEING
NONE, WE HAVE ONE ITEM.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1381. THANK YOU. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALLEN. AYE. ALVARADO.
GILL AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DELI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NILO. OCHOA.
BORG AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE.
NILO ISE 38 NOES. ZERO. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THAT
.
ALL RIGHT. AYES 38. NOES ZERO.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR, IT
PASSES. NOW IT'S TIME FOR
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS
.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
PURPOSE FOR ANNOUNCEMENTS
RECOGNIZED. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MISTER PRESIDENT, AS
STATED BY ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
EARLIER, HE MENTIONED TODAY WAS
TAX DAY. BUT FOR DODGER FANS,
TODAY IS JACKIE ROBINSON DAY.
AND THE DAY MARKS THE 77TH
ANNIVERSARY OF JACKIE ROBINSON
BREAKING THE COLOR BARRIER IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL. SO I
WANTED TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO RECOGNIZE HIS HISTORIC
ACCOMPLISHMENT AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT A TRAILBLAZING INDIVIDUAL
HE WAS, AND TO CELEBRATE HIS
LIFE AND HIS LEGACY THAT STILL
LIVES ON TODAY. SO TODAY MARKS
THE 77TH ANNIVERSARY, AND I KNOW
WE'RE ALL DODGER FANS HERE
TODAY. SO ON BEHALF OF JACKIE
ROBINSON, WE SAY GO BLUE.
STIRRING THE MEMORIES. ALL
RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK.
THANK YOU SIR, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. I WANT TO FIRST
RECOGNIZE SENATOR ALLEN. IF HE'S
PREPARED. SENATOR ALLEN, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. JURY MEMBER.
YES, SIR. MEMBERS. IT'S WITH A
VERY HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURN THE
SENATE IN MEMORY OF A TRULY
GREAT MAN. AND A FORMER MEMBER
OF THIS BODY, SENATOR ALAN
SIEROTY. AND I WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT WE'RE HONORED TO BE JOINED
TODAY BY ALAN'S FAMILY HERE IN
THE GALLERY, MICHELLE RAKOFF,
HIS LONGTIME PARTNER BETH, AND
DAVID MELTZER, HIS SISTER AND
HER HUSBAND, JULIA. AND JOSEPH
MELZER, ALAN'S NIECE AND NEPHEW.
AND EVAN KAISER, WHO WAS ALAN'S
LONGTIME FRIEND, FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF AND PRESIDENT OF THE
SAROTTI COMPANY. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO WERE NEVER FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO GET TO MEET ALAN, HE
WAS PERHAPS BEST INTRODUCED BY A
SACRAMENTO BEE ARTICLE PUBLISHED
IN JULY OF 1967, HIS FRESHMAN
YEAR IN THE ASSEMBLY, AND THE
HEADLINE NICKNAMED ALAN THE
UNDERDOG'S CHAMPION AND
DESCRIBED HOW HE ALREADY WAS
RESPECTED AS ONE OF THE MOST
CONSCIENTIOUS MEMBERS OF OUR
STATE ASSEMBLY. IT WENT ON TO
NOTE HIS ECONOMICS AND LAW
DEGREES FROM STANFORD AND USC,
AND REPORT ON HIS HUMANITARIAN
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS AND HIS
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. ALL THIS RAN ALONGSIDE A
PHOTO OF ALAN WITH HIS
UNDENIABLY GENUINE SMILE AND HIS
POSITIVE COMMENT THAT SOMETHING
THAT I WE ALL KNOW, THOSE OF US
WHO GOT ONE, THE WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW HIM IS HIS
WONDERFUL POSITIVITY IN THE
ARTICLE HE SAID THERE'S NOTHING
I WOULD RATHER BE DOING. BORN IN
LOS ANGELES IN 1930, ALAN JOINED
A FAMILY THAT HAD AN ESTABLISHED
TRADITION OF COMMUNITY WORK AND
INSTILLED IN HIM THE VALUES THAT
LED HIM TO A LIFE OF PUBLIC
SERVICE. AS HE AND HIS SIBLINGS
WERE GROWING UP. ALAN'S MOTHER,
JEANNE, WAS DEVOTED TO FOSTERING
A COMMUNITY OF PROGRESSIVE
PHILANTHROPY IN THE CITY AND WAS
KNOWN TO OPEN THEIR FAMILY HOME
TO HOST LEADERS SUCH AS ELEANOR
ROOSEVELT, PAUL ROBESON, CORETTA
SCOTT KING. HER ONGOING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
INVESTMENT LAID THE GROUNDWORK
FOR A GENERATION OF PROGRESSIVE
JEWISH ACTIVISTS,
PHILANTHROPISTS, AND POLITICAL
LEADERS. HER SON, ALAN, VERY
MUCH INCLUDED. ALAN GREW UP IN
LA AND WENT TO BEVERLY HILLS
HIGH SCHOOL, THEN WENT ON TO
STUDY ECONOMICS AT STANFORD LAW
AT USC, WENT ON TO BECOME THE
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY FOR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GLENN
ANDERSON, AND THEN DIRECTOR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILE PROGRAM, AND
THROUGH THOSE EXPERIENCES
GATHERED KNOWLEDGE AND THE
WILLPOWER NECESSARY TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE POLICY MAKER. HE RAN
FOR STATE ASSEMBLY IN 1966 AND
WAS THEN SWORN IN AND
IMMEDIATELY HIT THE GROUND
RUNNING AS AN AMBITIOUS, HOPEFUL
AND PREPARED LEGISLATOR.
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY VETO
LETTERS HE WOULD RECEIVE FROM
GOVERNOR REAGAN, ALAN WAS IN
MANY RESPECTS DECADES AHEAD OF
MOST OF HIS COLLEAGUES IN THE
PURSUIT OF PROGRESSIVE POLICIES.
AT A TIME WHEN THAT WAS MUCH
HARDER FIGHTING FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSERVATION,
LGBTQ RIGHTS, HOUSING,
DISABILITY RIGHTS, CIVIL RIGHTS,
CHILD CARE, DISMANTLING RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION, FIGHTING FOR THE
RIGHTS AND DIGNITY OF EVERY
CALIFORNIAN WAS AT THE CORE OF
ALAN'S LEGISLATIVE MISSION, AND
HE INTRODUCED BILLS YEAR AFTER
YEAR TO PROTECT THE VULNERABLE
AMONG SO MANY OTHERS. HE
INTRODUCED A NUMBER OF BILLS TO
TRY TO CREATE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS, ESPECIALLY WITH
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS. HE FOUGHT
AGAINST INSTITUTIONAL SEXISM
WITHIN POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND
BROUGHT REFORMS OF BIAS,
PHYSICAL QUALIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. HE PUSHED TO END
THE POLICE PRACTICE OF HARASSING
AND ENTRAPPING GAY MEN IN THE
COMMUNITY, CHARGING THEM WITH
LEWD CONDUCT WHICH UNJUSTLY
CARRIED REGISTRATION AS A SEX
OFFENDER AT HIS RETIREMENT
EVENT. IN 1982. IN FACT, RAMONA
RIPSTON, THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE ACLU OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, REFERRED TO ALAN AS
JUST ABOUT THE BEST FRIEND CIVIL
LIBERTIES HAVE EVER HAD IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE. YEAR AFTER
YEAR, ALAN WOULD INTRODUCE A
BILL TO BAN CAPITAL PUNISHMENT
IN CALIFORNIA, BILL THAT HAD
FIRST BEEN INTRODUCED, THAT HAD
BEEN INTRODUCED ANNUALLY FOR
OVER 20 YEARS, ONLY TO DIE IN
ITS FIRST COMMITTEE, AND TO HIS
CREDIT, HE EVENTUALLY GOT THE
BILL OUT OF COMMITTEE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN YEARS. HE CALLED
ON THE REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA TO DIVEST PUBLIC
FUNDS FROM ANY COMPANIES DOING
BUSINESS IN SOUTH AFRICA. AMID
APARTHEID, SAYING RECENT
PROTESTS HAVE RAISED ONCE AGAIN
THE LONG STANDING ISSUE OF
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY IN THE
CORPORATE INVESTMENT POLICIES OF
PUBLIC ENTITIES. AND A FEW YEARS
LATER, ALAN AGAIN CALLED ON THE
UK'S 25 REGENT BOARD TO END ITS
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE US MILITARY
NUCLEAR ARMS RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT AT THE LOS ALAMOS
AND LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
FACILITIES, AND ALONG WITH LIKE
MINDED COLLEAGUES, HE VOCALLY
OPPOSED PRESIDENT NIXON'S PLAN
TO BOMB POPULATION CENTERS IN
VIETNAM. HE TOOK OUT FULL PAGE
ADS IN PAPERS LIKE THE LA TIMES
TO HIGHLIGHT THE DEVASTATION OF
VIETNAMESE HOSPITALS AND CALL
FOR HUMANITARIAN AID. HE WAS A
GIFTED POLITICAL MESSENGER AND
POLICY MAKER BECAUSE HE HE NEVER
TOOK A MOMENT OF HIS TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR GRANTED. IN
FACT, WITH ONLY FOUR MINUTES
LEFT BEFORE HIS RESIGNATION FROM
THE ASSEMBLY TO BECOME A
SENATOR, HE CAST THE DECISIVE
41ST VOTE OVER THERE TO PASS A
CONTROVERSIAL BAN OF AEROSOL
CONTAINERS, AND TEN MINUTES
LATER HE RAN OVER HERE, WAS
SWORN IN AS A SENATOR AND GOT
RIGHT BACK TO WORK. WHEN BANK OF
AMERICA HAD RELEASED A DEAR
CUSTOMER LETTER IN 1975
DETAILING THEIR JUSTIFICATIONS
FOR INTEREST RATE HIKES, THE LA
TIMES TOLD THE STORY OF THE TWO
VOWS THAT HE MADE THAT DAY, THAT
HE WAS DONE USING HIS CREDIT
CARD AFTER FEBRUARY 28TH, AND
THAT HE'D RUN A BILL TO STOP
THIS KIND OF PREDATORY INTEREST
HIKE. HIS YEARS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDSHIP AT THE CAPITOL
HIGHLIGHT HIS UNDERSTANDING OF
THE INFLECTION POINT OUR STATE
WAS AT AT THE TIME, AND THE
DRASTIC MEASURES NECESSARY TO
PROTECT IT. HE PROPOSED BILLS TO
RETAIN STATE OWNERSHIP OF OIL
FIELDS AND TO PROTECT STATE
PARKS FROM EXPLOITATIVE PRIVATE
CONCESSION. HE FOUGHT HARD FOR A
BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE 75% OF
GOVERNMENT VEHICLE FLEETS TO BE
COMPACT CARS, WHICH WOULD HAVE
IMMENSELY REDUCED COSTS OF FUEL
SCARCITY AND COLLISIONS. HE
FAMOUSLY ASKED IN A COMMITTEE
HEARING ON CORPORATE
REPRESENTATION ON REGIONAL WATER
BOARDS, WHY SHOULD WE HAVE THE
POLLUTERS REGULATING THE
QUESTION OF WATER QUALITY? GOOD
QUESTION FOR US TO ASK TODAY.
BUT ALAN'S FLAGSHIP
ENVIRONMENTAL ACHIEVEMENT AND
CORNERSTONE OF HIS LEGACY ALMOST
CERTAINLY WAS HIS INSTRUMENTAL
WORK TO ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION, THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL ACT, THE BODY
THAT TO THIS DAY ENSURES THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS REAP THE
BENEFITS OF OUR INCREDIBLE
CLOTHES LINE. FOR YEARS, ALAN
WOULD INTRODUCE STRONG COASTAL
PROTECTION BILLS AND GO UP
AGAINST GROUPS LIKE THE
COMMITTEE OPPOSED TO ECOLOGY
ISSUES, WHICH WAS A BROAD
COALITION OF LOBBYISTS WHO WOULD
MEET IN ROOM 704 OF THE SENATOR
HOTEL TO KILL US TO STRATEGIZE
ABOUT KILLING COASTAL PROTECTION
BILLS. WHAT A WHAT A WONDERFUL
NAME, THE COMMITTEE OPPOSED TO
ECOLOGY ISSUES. EVENTUALLY, ALAN
PROVED TO BE THE LINCHPIN WHEN
HE HELPED LEAD THE EFFORT TO
QUALIFY A COASTAL PROTECTION
BALLOT INITIATIVE, WHICH THEN
FORCED THE ISSUE BEYOND SPECIAL
INTERESTS AND INTO THE HANDS OF
THE CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. AND THE
PASSAGE OF WHICH ESTABLISHED THE
COASTAL COMMISSION AND ONE OF
THE MANY WONDERFUL LEGACIES THAT
CELEBRATED OF SENATOR SOROTI.
HIS COLLEAGUES DECIDED TO NAME A
BEAUTIFUL, STUNNING, AN ISOLATED
BEACH TUCKED AWAY IN TOMALES BAY
, WHICH WHICH NOW HOLDS THE
LEGACY THAT FITTINGLY HOLDS THE
LEGACY OF ITS NAMESAKE. WHEN
FOLKS VISIT ALAN'S BEACH,
CALIFORNIANS ARE IMMERSED ON ALL
SIDES BY THE PRISTINE PIECE OF
OUR COAST PRESERVED IN ITS
NATURAL STATE, AND SOMETHING
THAT ALAN WOULD BE SO PROUD OF,
SOMETHING HE FOUGHT SO HARD FOR.
IN ADDITION TO HIS ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK, HE FOUGHT FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING, CHILD CARE
CENTER FUNDING WITH 80 NEW
FACILITIES, PENSION PROTECTIONS
FOR TEACHERS AND PUBLIC
SERVANTS. HE WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE RIGHTS OF THE
DISABILITY OF THE DISABLED. ALAN
PASSED LEGISLATION THAT
PROTECTED WORKS OF ART. HE
ENSURED THAT ARTISTS RECEIVE
ROYALTIES FOR THE RESALE OF
PIECES. HE PROTECTED ARTISTS
OWNERSHIP OF THEIR WORK. WHEN
HIRED. HE MOST NOTABLY HELPED TO
ESTABLISH THE STATE SUMMER
SCHOOL FOR THE ARTS AND REMAINED
AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THEIR BOARD.
THE PROGRAM WILL SOON BE
CONVENING ITS 35TH CLASS OF
YOUNG ARTISTS, ADDING TO THE
17,000 THAT HAVE EARNED THEIR
PLACE IN THE PROGRAM SINCE ITS
INCEPTION AND SEEDING. THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CALIFORNIA
ARTISTS. ALAN ALSO FOUGHT FOR
YEARS FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
PERCENT OF ART LAW, A POLICY
ENSURING THE INCLUSION OF PUBLIC
ART AND LOCAL ARTISTS IN
PROJECTS, AND HE SUCCEEDED IN
ESTABLISHING A NUMBER OF LOCAL
VERSIONS THAT BROUGHT LONG TIME
INVESTMENT TO CALIFORNIA ARTS.
AND NOW I AM HUMBLED TO SERVE AS
THE VICE CHAIR OF OUR JOINT
COMMITTEE ON THE ARTS, WHICH WAS
THE VERY COMMITTEE THAT ALAN
ESTABLISHED IN 1981, FURTHERING
ITS MISSION OF EXPANDING ACCESS
TO AND INVESTMENT IN THE ARTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AS NOTED BY
CONGRESSMAN GARAMENDI IN HIS
RECENT REMARKS HONORING ALAN ON
THE ON THE US HOUSE FLOOR, HIS
COMMITMENT TO HIS COMMUNITY
EXPANDED BEYOND HIS EXTENSIVE
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE. UPON
RETIRING FROM THE LEGISLATURE IN
1982, ALAN IMMEDIATELY ACCEPTED
POSITIONS ON ABOUT A DOZEN
BOARDS OF ORGANIZATIONS AND
SPENT THE NEXT FEW DECADES
DEEPLY ENGAGED IN HIS COMMUNITY.
AT EVERY LEVEL, INCLUDING
NONPROFIT BOARDS. HE WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
PROGRESSIVE JEWISH ALLIANCE. HE
SUPPORTED FAR MORE THAN HIS FAIR
SHARE OF LOCAL ARTISTS AND
NEIGHBORS IN THE COMMUNITY. AS
WELL, HE WAS ALSO PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH THE LOS ANGELES
FAMILY HOUSING ORGANIZATION TO
CONVERT A HOTEL INTO THE
SAROTTI, A HOUSING PROJECT THAT
HAS PROVIDED INTERIM HOUSING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR 75
INDIVIDUALS TRANSITIONING OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS. BEFORE ITS
CONVERSION TO PERMANENT
SUPPORTING HOUSING. ALAN'S NIECE
UP HERE, JULIA, WHO IS IN THE
GALLERY TODAY, IS THE FOUNDER OF
CLOCK SHOP, WHICH IS A NONPROFIT
DEVOTED TO CONNECTING PEOPLE,
THE PEOPLE OF LOS ANGELES, TO
THE PUBLIC LANDS AND CULTURAL
HERITAGE OF THE REGION THROUGH
THE ARTS, AND POIGNANTLY NAMED
FOR HER GREAT GRANDFATHER'S
FIRST BUSINESS IN LA. JULIA'S
WORK IS ONE EXAMPLE OF THE NEXT
GENERATION OF COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP AND INVESTMENT, TO
WHICH ALAN DEVOTED HIS LIFETIME
OF SERVICE. I WAS SO FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO GET TO MEET ALAN LATER
IN HIS LIFE, WHEN I WAS ACTUALLY
WHEN I WAS FIRST WRITING FOR
THIS SEAT AND I JUST REALLY
TREASURED THE MEMORIES OF THE
LUNCHES AND CONVERSATIONS I WAS
ABLE TO HAVE WITH HIM, BOTH AS A
CANDIDATE AND THEN AS A SENATOR.
WE GOT TOGETHER AT HIS OFFICE AT
HIS BELOVED LACMA RIGHT NEAR THE
LA BREA TAR PITS. HE, OF COURSE,
IT ALSO WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAKING THE SABER TOOTHED CAT OUR
STATE FOSSIL, AND I JUST LOVED
HIS POSITIVITY AND HIS OPENNESS,
HIS KINDNESS. YOU KNOW, THIS
THIS IS A WAY WE ALL SPEND A LOT
OF TIME HERE WORKING REALLY
HARD. AND YET THEN WE MOVE ON TO
OTHER THINGS. WE'RE ALL TIME
LIMITED. AND I PREPARING FOR
THIS REALLY GOT ME THINKING A
LOT ABOUT LEGACY AND WHAT WHAT
WE ALL WANT TO LAY DOWN, AND
WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
LASTS BEYOND US. AND I JUST
THROUGH STUDYING THE WORK OF
SENATOR SOROTI, I THERE'S SO
MANY THINGS THAT WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED TODAY THAT COMES AS A
RESULT OF HIS WORK. EVERY, YOU
KNOW, PUBLIC BEACH THAT'S BEEN
PROTECTED UP AND DOWN THE COAST.
EVERY YOUNG ARTIST WHO WAS GIVEN
A REAL OPPORTUNITY CONTINUES TO
BE EVERY FAMILY THAT'S RELIED ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION, SUPPORT OR
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE. EVERY
LEGISLATOR THAT ENTERS THIS
HOUSE OF DEMOCRACY WITH AN
UNRELENTING RESOLVE TO BEAR THE
EXPERIENCE OF EACH CALIFORNIAN
AND INTERCEDE WITH EMPATHY, HIS
HEART, AND HIS VISION FOR
CALIFORNIA AND ESPECIALLY ITS
UNDERPRIVILEGED, ARE INDELIBLY
INKED ON THE STATE AND ON THIS
CHAMBER, GUIDING THOSE OF US
WITH THE PRIVILEGE OF FOLLOWING
IN HIS FOOTSTEPS. AS I WAS
MENTIONING TO MICHELLE, WHO WAS
IN TOUCH WITH SPEAKER PELOSI
RIGHT WHEN ALAN WENT INTO
HOSPICE CARE AND SPEAKER WROTE
BACK TO HER AND SAID, PLEASE
THANK HIM ON MY BEHALF FOR HIS
GREATNESS AND HIS GOODNESS.
MEMBERS, I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
TODAY IN REMEMBERING THE
INCREDIBLE LIFE AND SELFLESS
COMMUNITY SERVICE OF THE
HONORABLE ALAN SOROTI BY
ADJOURNING TODAY IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES AND APPRECIATION FOR
SENATOR CERATI, SENATOR STERN,
THANK YOU. I THERE'S VERY LITTLE
I CAN ADD. I'LL JUST GIVE A
PERSONAL NOTE, MEASURE OF A
LEADER IS NOT JUST BY WHAT THEY
DO, BUT THOSE WHO THEY BRING UP
BEHIND THEM, AND SO I'M SO
GRATEFUL TO ALAN FOR BEING A
MENTOR FOR, NOT JUST SENATOR
ALAN, BUT PEOPLE LIKE ME AND FOR
EVERYBODY WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE
AS A KID TO GROW UP NEAR THE
BEACH, I WAS A KID IN MALIBU WHO
JUST TOOK TOOK THAT AS A SORT OF
RITE OF PASSAGE THAT THERE'S THE
OCEAN. AND IT'S FOR US. BUT THAT
WAS NOT A FOREGONE CONCLUSION.
AND IN MY LITTLE HOMETOWN OF
MALIBU, THERE WERE OTHER PLANS
TO BUILD MANSIONS AND TO GO
BLOCK ALL THAT ACCESS, ALAN WAS
OF THOSE COMMUNITIES. SO IT'S
THE HARDEST TO GO SAY NO TO YOUR
OWN PEOPLE. SO FOR THAT KIND OF
COURAGE AND FOR EVERY KID NOW
GROWING UP IN LA, AND THERE ARE
MILLIONS OF THEM WHO NOW SEE
THAT OCEAN AS PART OF THEIRS,
TOO, NOT JUST FOR THE PRIVILEGED
FEW. I AM GRATEFUL I KNOW THEY
ARE TOO, AND I HOPE, I HOPE HIS
NAME WILL WILL BE ON OUR HEARTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR WE ADJOURN
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THAT YOU BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE. NEXT UP
IS SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN THE SENATE IN
MEMORY OF ONE OF OUR FORMER
STATE SENATE COLLEAGUES. HIS
FATHER, EDWARD MORRIS SCHIFF,
AFFECTIONATELY KNOWN AS BOCA.
EDDIE ED SCHIFF WAS BORN IN
BOSTON, MASSACHUSETTS, IN 1928,
THE SON OF MARTHA AND FRANK
SCHIFF. HE ATTENDED BOSTON
ENGLISH HIGH SCHOOL, BUT LEFT
EARLY TO JOIN THE SERVICE IN THE
MID 1940S. DURING WORLD WAR II,
PART OF THE GREATEST GENERATION,
HE FIRST TRIED TO ENLIST IN THE
MARINE CORPS, BUT FAILED THE
PHYSICAL DUE TO FLAT FEET AND
BAD EYESIGHT. TWO WEEKS LATER,
ED SCHIFF WOULD TRY TO ENLIST IN
THE ARMY AND APPARENTLY DURING
THAT TWO WEEK PERIOD, THE DOCTOR
WHO EXAMINED HIM FOR THE MARINE
CORPS, THE SAME DOCTOR WHO WAS
EXAMINING HIM FOR THE ARMY,
BECAME MUCH SMARTER AND
DISCERNING, AND SO HE ENLISTED
IN THE ARMY. REASON HE WAS
ADMITTED, ENLISTED IN THE ARMY
IS BECAUSE THE DOCTOR SAID,
WEREN'T YOU JUST HERE? YOU
REALLY WANT TO GO INTO THE
SERVICE THAT BAD? SCHIFF SAID
YES, AND HE WAS ENLISTED IN THE
ARMY AFTER ED'S SERVICE IN THE
ARMY, HE WENT ON TO COLLEGE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF ALABAMA. HE
LEFT COLLEGE AFTER TWO YEARS TO
BECOME A LUMPER IN THE SHMATA
BUSINESS, THEN A TRAVELING
SALESMAN, AND THEN MUCH LATER
WORKING IN THE LUMBER AND GUNITE
BUSINESS. BUT BOCA. EDDIE WOULD
ALWAYS SAY THAT THE BIGGEST SALE
HE EVER MADE WAS WHEN HE MET
CHERYL ANN GLOVSKY, AND THEY
MARRIED IN 1956, SETTLING IN
WESTERN MASSACHUSETTS. THE
SHIFTS EVENTUALLY FOUND THEIR
WAY OUT WEST, FIRST TO
SCOTTSDALE, ARIZONA IN 1970 AND
THEN EVENTUALLY TO ALAMO,
CALIFORNIA, WHERE THE SHIFTS
WOULD RAISE THEIR TWO SONS,
DANIEL AND ADAM. YEARS LATER, ED
SCHIFF WOULD SETTLE IN FLORIDA
AND THAT'S WHERE HE WAS KNOWN AS
BOCA. EDDIE ED WAS LOVING,
GENEROUS, STRONG, STOIC. HE
TREATED OTHERS AS HE WANTED TO
BE TREATED WITH RESPECT,
AFFECTION, AND OPENNESS THAT WAS
RARE FOR HIS GENERATION. I KNOW
PERSONALLY THE PRIDE HE TOOK IN
HIS CHILDREN AND HIS
GRANDCHILDREN, AND HE WAS HE HAD
A SENSE OF HUMOR, SOMETIMES A
RACY SENSE OF HUMOR. HE WAS
STUBBORNLY DEVOTED TO HIS
FAMILY, HIS FRIENDS, HIS
EMPLOYEES, HIS WIFE, CHERYL ANN.
WHEN CHERYL WAS OLDER AND AILING
FROM YEARS OF ALZHEIMER'S, HE
CARED FOR HER AT HOME UNTIL
WEEKS BEFORE SHE PASSED. ED IS
SURVIVED BY HIS SISTER, JUDY
SOKOL, HIS UNCLE LEON SCHIFF,
HIS TWO SONS, DANIEL AND ADAM,
HIS DAUGHTERS IN LAW AMY AND EVE
. HIS GRANDCHILDREN RACHEL,
FRANK, LEXI AND ELI, AND HIS
GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER MAYA.
COLLEAGUES, I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN HONOR OF EDWARD
MORRIS SCHIFF. THANK YOU,
SENATOR UMBERG, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY AND
ASK THAT YOU BRING THE NAME
FORWARD SO IT CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
OCHOA BOGH
.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS,
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
SANDRA ORPHALI, WHO PASSED AWAY
AT HER HOME IN RANCHO CUCAMONGA
IN FEBRUARY AT THE AGE OF 80.
SANDY SPENT 40 YEARS WITH THE
ALTA LOMA SCHOOL DISTRICT, AND
ALMOST 50 YEARS AS A VOLUNTEER
FOR THE AMERICAN YOUTH SOCCER
ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS AYSO FOR
34 YEARS. OF THOSE 50 YEARS, SHE
WAS ALSO AYSO AREA DIRECTOR. SHE
WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL MANAGEMENT COUNCIL,
GENERATING MANY OF THE POSITION
HANDBOOKS AND TRAINING MATERIALS
USED TODAY IN YOUTH SOCCER. AS A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER, SANDY CITY
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
EXCELLENCE HELPED THE DISTRICT
MAINTAIN ITS REPUTATION AS A
LEADING EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION.
IN SANDY'S CONTRIBUTIONS WERE
COUNTLESS. SHE WAS A MENTOR, A
ROLE MODEL, AN INSPIRATION FOR
MANY. HER LEGACY IS NOT JUST IN
THE POLICIES OR THE PROGRAMS SHE
INITIATED, BUT THE COUNTLESS
LIVES SHE ENRICHED AND THE
COMMUNITY SHE HELPED BUILD. TO
HONOR HER PROFOUND LEGACY, THE
ALTA LOMA SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD
OF TRUSTEES WILL NAME THE EAST
FIELD AT ALTA LOMA JUNIOR HIGH
SCHOOL, A CENTRAL HUB FOR AYSO
ACTIVITIES AND A PLACE CLOSE TO
SANDY'S HEART, THE SANDY ORPHALI
FIELD. SANDY'S PASSION FOR AND
DEDICATION TO YOUTH SOCCER MAKES
THIS FIELD THE FITTING SYMBOL OF
HER REMARKABLE IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITY. I WISH SANDY'S FAMILY
AND FRIEND PEACE AND COMFORT
DURING THIS TIME OF DEEP SORROW.
I WOULD BE HONORED IF THIS BODY
WOULD ADJOURN IN SANDY'S MEMORY.
THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES AND ASK THAT YOU
BRING THE NAME FORWARD SO SHE
CAN BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED.
NOW MEMBERS, IT'S TIME FOR
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. DO WE
HAVE ANNOUNCEMENTS? SENATOR MIN,
SENATE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WATER COMMITTEE WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 1200 IN THE
SWING SPACE. NATURAL RESOURCES
WILL MEET IN ROOM 1200 UPON
ADJOURNMENT. SENATOR ALVARADO
GILL, COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES WILL MEET UPON
ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM 2200 AND
SWING SPACE HUMAN SERVICES WILL
MEET IN ROOM 2200 UPON
ADJOURNMENT. SENATOR ASHBY,
WHERE IS SHE
?
MEMBERS B AND E WILL RESUME IN
ROOM 2100, AFTER THE FLOOR. UPON
ADJOURNMENT. IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
, MR. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS.
HAPPY MONDAY. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY, APRIL 18TH AT 9 A.M.
VERY GRATEFUL, MR. PRESIDENT.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE'LL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT 9
A.M.